the teammate journey if you look at it
from seven years ago
started with a focus on this foundry
model that builds new companies from
scratch this was the sole thing that
we've done
and also cyber security was the sole
focus
so we created this 42 million dollar
fund that was aimed at
building five new companies partnering
with amazing entrepreneurs
to do the ideation process together and
found new companies
uh from scratch welcome to 20 minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel stanford
episode 400.
what well i have an amazing guest with
us today
a great friend mentor just an incredible
guy
liran greenberg managing partner of
teammate capital
and co-founder of team 8. liran is the
co-founder of team 8 and the managing
partner of its investment fund
teammate capital leron invests at seed
and a-rounds in enterprise technology
cyber security and data
companies he co-founded team 8 in 2014
initially focusing on the design of team
8's company building foundry model
working closely with the founding teams
of curve acquired by paypal
port shift acquired by cisco signia
acquired by
temesek and others liran then
transitioned to lead teammates marketing
business development and market research
functions
alongside the formation of the teamaid
village a tight-knit community of
hundreds of enterprise executives
good to meet you in person it's weird
meeting in person i'm used to seeing you
only on facebook but
i i guess you're real now and we're in
the beautiful teammate offices i can't
believe you have
you're spanning six floors in this
beautiful building in the middle of tel
aviv
and in new york with some incredible
companies today we're leading the
teammate capital finals
and doing some amazing investments and
i'm just shocked
having seen a little bit of the growth
having visited here for the first time i
think
seven years ago seeing what happened
with with teammate
and you know one of the questions that i
asked you did you expect this to become
like that
and i think that's where i want to start
lilan did you expect
teammate to be what it is today uh we're
an ambitious group but i don't i don't
think we've uh
when we started seven years ago we've
known where where it is today
we were always thinking of things
differently and started with a unique
model
of how um how we form companies on our
heart startup are
start starting and build uh we didn't
know it will become the venture group
that it is today we didn't know the
the the sectors that we will develop
into but it's very exciting it's been
a hell of a seven years to date so i
have to tell you secret for the five
years that i was in 8200
every time i walked through the the
halls and i kept seeing the team leaders
and i thought of myself as a team leader
i kept thinking back to lyron's story
a team leader a tech leader and
in america that went after the army to
create a company with
the head of the unit and the commander
of the commander of his own commander
and i kept thinking like how is that
possible like that's like that has to be
the most extraordinary way
to leave the unit so that's that's not
exactly the story but i'll walk you
through it so
i did served for six years in 8200
i was working under under israel's
command which is one of the co-founders
and nadav
was the commander of the unit all
together
but i i worked very closely with israel
more so
than with nadav back then i was actually
running a team
as a junior officer i had my own role
but somehow
occasionally i was called to help israel
which i didn't knew at the time i just
knew who he is but we never met before
uh to help with some presentation and
somehow i remember that night
lasting until four a.m and and we we've
bonded and and
ever since you know for a few years time
we just worked on additional projects
alongside my official role and israel
saw
saw in me i think like a good
representation of the
uh generation that is not immigrants to
the digital world as you see
himself that he wasn't born with the
computer in his hand but we did
and and in all sorts of uh you know big
events
uh some important strategic discussion
he brought me as this
young generation representation today we
are old we weren't born with you know uh
iphones in our
and touch screens in our head but back
in the days let's say we were
kind of like the digital native where
their generation was
uh immigrants if you'd like anyhow we
had this
great relationship i um i left 8200
after six years
and i've spent at the opportunity to
actually work
um and do product management roles
before starting teammate
yeah so it's not right after i actually
had the
um i had the opportunity to do two
startups that become unicorns i led
product
management for the apis and developers
platforms at conduit
which had a quarter of a billion daily
active users was going like the most
successful internet company at the time
and it was a great great uh school for
product management
in 8200 did engineering and then led
engineering teams and then
uh condo conduit was where i led i i
will learn
product management and then very uh
relevant these days i did another role
at
etoro a social investment network a
fintech company
that today officially announced they're
going ipos threw us back for
10 and something billion dollars and he
tore is exploding now
uh which is a great proud to see you
choose the before teaming
yeah not only that my boss was ronen
who's one of the founders
and today i'm very proud not only to
call my former boss but now also a
partner
a teammate so he's my partner now we as
we expanded to build teammate fintech
one of the first
uh you know names that came to mind was
ronan was one of the people that i liked
the most
from my time at uh editorial and we're
very happy for him
to celebrate this very exciting day for
etoro and he's still very involved in
the company and on its board but
also now a partner in our new fintech
practice
so from engineering a200 deep
technology engineering to product
management to
venture building and now to capital walk
me through this
who like what are you from all of those
different trades
so i think a a well-rounded person is
true engineering
leading engineering teams product
management then entrepreneurship and
company building
my chapter two within the teammate
journey which we can talk about more is
actually go to market
which is really kind of like um a
different aspect of a startup company
and nowadays i think bringing all these
diverse background into
investments and working with the
companies that i invest in but the
teammate journey if you look at it
from seven years ago started with a
focus on this foundry model
that builds new companies from scratch
this was the sole thing that we've done
and also cyber security was the sole
focus so we created this 42 million
dollar fund that was aimed at
building five new companies partnering
with amazing entrepreneurs
to do the ideation process together and
found new companies
uh from scratch right with those amazing
founders um
and we imagined a platform that will
take what two entrepreneurs do
in the garage up until then and make a
profession out of it make it more
methodic
married make it more resourceful and
hopefully uh dramatically increase the
chances of success
so it makes perfect sense in hindsight
you go back you're looking at the
incredible companies i think at your
third exit just in the past
two weeks or so it will curve with
paypal
you're sitting there with israel and
you're you're coming up with these
different models that weren't very
popular back then
especially not in the cyber security
world which in itself is very niche
specifically also in israel what was the
aha like why why this thesis how did you
even arrive to this idea
um first of all you write it wasn't very
popular and i remember going on a plane
with nadav to fundraise and we got a lot
a lot of uh
no's and uh that model to begin with was
not very popular and a lot of people
were telling us go build one successful
company before you try to teach everyone
how to build companies or do a company
that builds multiple ones which is a
very legit
feedback to give us and still um
maybe uh if you look at nadav and israel
just graduating out of 25 years in the
military system
and go they had this fresh look and the
way
you know we phrased it back then is if
you look at how innovation
was brought to the world it's let's say
generally in three ways one is through
the academia
which has this amazing deep research
capabilities
but lack maybe the commercial aspects of
it like the focus maybe throwing things
too way into the future and not
uh solving problems of today um there's
incumbents you know the big enterprises
that really understand the customers
they have great resources access to the
customers
but you know bureaucratic slow to
innovate as we know today
and their startup companies which are
agile and laser focused
and you know dynamic but very
resourceless right they don't have the
access they don't have a lot of capital
and then we said okay maybe if we'll
build a platform that will try to bring
the good of all these worlds
the deep research capabilities of the
academia the
you know market access that the big
incumbents have but preserve
the agility of a startup maybe there's a
model that can actually increase the
chances of success
and the teammate platform that we've
built actually consists today of like
10 people doing research in-house data
scientists sex attackers engineers
typically funds do not have this uh and
at scale also academia relations we have
someone full time just um you know
working on extracting
research in academia that we can
commercialize potentially
so we have that we have a very strong
go-to-market team
and a village of enterprise executives
surrounding it
to really give us the understanding of
the problems in the market space and
and access to the design partners with
uh
kind of deep relational relationships
even before we started the journey
and and these ingredients um we wrapped
it with a process a very thematic
process of saying first
let's come up with let's research and
find a big problem that we believe if we
solve it there's a great opportunity
behind it
then let's do ideation of try to bring
technology innovation to solve it
and thereafter really validated
extensively with this village
and then we're ready kind of like to
spin off a new company to the
marketplace
so take me to the founders perspective
you have a founder that's now joining
team eight
and is joining this this beautiful
rapper they they have all these
different resources to pull from
they have all these different experts in
the capital and and a beautiful building
in the middle of tel aviv
and and just all and amazing enterprise
specialists they're going to be part
potential partners of them down the line
is how is their experience compared to
the average entrepreneur
out of their garage with a couple of
friends raising the right the regular
rounds of startup how does that how do
you differ so first important to say
that today
teammate has evolved before answering
the questions teammate has evolved so
today we have two
foundry funds and two foundry activities
one and uh partnering with entrepreneurs
early on
to build cyber and ai companies the
other the newer one
is to do the same in fintech but then we
have teammate capital
which invests in companies like more
like in the regular vc world so this is
where
up until now we haven't done it but in
the last uh year and a half or so
we have deal flow we meet entrepreneurs
and then we can lead see
serious uh seed and a rounds uh in
companies so this is more like a
regular vc model so we have both today
uh which is important
to note our platform supports companies
whether they were incubated within
teammates foundry vehicles or
if we invested in them through teammate
capital we still support them
but still i think the there's definitely
a unique process within the foundry
vehicle
and this is just it's about timing it's
about a great entrepreneurial team
that um does not necessarily have the
idea yet does not necessarily know even
the big problem that he wants to solve
um the way we do it is we have this
today 50 people team
including the partners that bring a lot
of domain expertise and company building
expertise
but these teams focused on go to market
and research and as well as
hr and recruitment of teams that work
for the founders the founders is
in the at the center it's true that in
the family we all reside in the same
building because we're working very
closely to one another
both in tel aviv and in new york and the
process is actually
through the faces that i described it's
very methodic and the first phase of
defining the problem
it's actually there's a gate summarizing
it
and then we go to the next stage of
ideation and there's a gate summarizing
where we crack the idea
and then a final gate for validation but
important to note that this process is
also very collaborative with our village
so for example these gates is where we
bring all of our strategic investors
around the table i think that i think i
showed you the picture of 40 or 50
people in a room
four hours per gate per company three
gates per company in their process and
then we
at the gate we just summarize all the
past few months of research
sharing all the dilemmas the you know
the challenges
and you have all these companies
microsoft cisco walmart
barclays uh moody's uh att
softbank which are teammate lp investors
but they're also kind of
design partners and part of the company
building process
and the idea is our companies now
meet more than 100 potential customers
until they kind of
graduate this process is to really be
validation
obsessed and to de-risk the product the
process making sure that we're building
uh we're solving for a big problem
and if we solve it uh there's a big
opportunity behind it
and and just increase the chances of
success so it literally sounds like an
accelerator for the lifetime of the
company
including you know these feedback
sessions that otherwise would take
months to get to if you can even get to
these people and having them
concentrated focused on your company
with
incentivized to help you and and provide
you with
feedback not just we don't like it but
here's why here is how we would improve
and here's how we could potentially see
ourselves interacting with this product
you know down the line which which i can
just imagine correct and it's uh
we do it one-on-one like this new
company and walmart let's say
but there's also in these gate sessions
it's all of them come together
and this is where magic happens right
you have the retail perspective and you
have the banking perspective when you
have us perspective you have
european perspective and it's all around
one table so you can actually debate
together and the insights that the
founding team gets out of these
discussions
is really phenomenal is it still
intimate
it sounds to me from knowing from a few
years that it was very very intimate
it's like
it's a family that you all are are
working closely together
is it still like this now that it's
growing so much look it's not the same
teammate you know it's it's still small
companies 50 people but it's not the
three or four people that we were back
then
but if you look at the gates you know
yeah there are still the same kind of
like 40 people the relevant people for
that specific company
and that specific domain and it actually
it works very nicely because
the way we've structured although the
group is now bigger
all of us the partners and the employees
everybody might have
part of the gp part of the equity stake
in whatever we're building
each of us have a stake in all the
different funds and all the different
activities
so when sarita and myself are leading an
a round in a finta company or a cyber
company
it's right it's our responsibility and
we're doing the deal but
um the let's say it's a fintech company
so the partners in our fintech practices
uh practice rakefed yuval ronin will
chime in to help us due diligence and
vet this opportunity and when we make
the investment of course they'll support
it and help it and we all
succeed if any of those companies
succeed same goes for
us so sarit and myself see the deal flow
learner a lot from it
those insights are you know transitioned
back to the foundries building new
companies it's all
one brand one family uh uh working very
synergetically together
why why are you having so much fun what
what is it about
your day your year i mean honestly it
sounds like a fairy tale story i'm sure
that there's a lot of hurdles along the
way
from everywhere but you know considering
they know that what what
type of story one could have in the
israeli ecosystem i can't imagine a much
better story than what than what you're
telling me here
and honestly i i love what you guys are
doing here it's inspiring just to see
you know that it's very humble people
sitting together
thinking really critically about real
world issues incubating them without all
the big
huge pr sitting down working really
really hard
and at the end just show incredible
results and seeing teammate as a company
grow
and as an organization but for you
legend what has been the part of it that
you've seen
wow like i'm so passionate about this or
this is why i wake up
yeah i think we're just um a lot of us
in in the venture ecosystem
generally we're just very ha very lucky
to be working with super smart people
uh which is just energizing i think for
me i'm
i'm i'm very lucky to be working with
the partners that i have a teammate
these are people that have built
um two unicorn uh companies and uh
others that have done multiple exits and
other that led thousands of people
mended thousands of people these are i'm
working i'm i'm
young and much less experienced than all
of them and i'm working with phenomenal
uh people every day and and generally
like a lot of us again in the venture
ecosystem we're working with
brilliant founders super committed
and uh and ambitious um and
and it's just you know it's a it's a job
that you can't uh
it's it's never boring and always fun uh
and i think we
um i think we want to kind of like
invest in and build
big big companies and and get them to
success
i i it's just exciting and it's it's
never a dull moment i think
as the group expands to more areas you
know we were focused laser focused on
cyber
now we're doing ai we're doing data
infrastructure cloud infrastructure
devops we're doing fintech
still very um domain expertise driven
still very
focused but again getting into new
domains
the group will eventually want to also
start a digital health
foundry thereafter we will also invest
in digital health companies that's kind
of like where
we want to take our cyber and data
expertise too eventually someday not
necessarily now
because we've expanded quite a lot so
never a dull moment
a lot of learning new things entering
new domains working with incredible
people
um couldn't be happier was there ever an
imposter syndrome
that you felt meaning what
you're young you're joining forces with
the commander of your commander of your
commander and his commander
two figures that are arguably some of
the most incredible people in the
israeli
cyber ecosystem and now you're at the
table with them now you're a partner
and you're the same caliber like this
yes there was management and other
things in between but
you know i i'm imagining myself sitting
down with my own commanders now
it's scary yeah i know
scare was nothing and nowhere near it i
think
i don't know we had great chemistry i
think we complement one another i'm
really privileged to to be working
again with partners like them but yeah
i can't say also that i plan for it you
know i was
before we started teammate i was working
at etoro i was
um and then when when the discussions
with nadav and israel back then
uh came to life i was nowhere near
thinking of living etoro i loved the
toro i really believed in the company i
was
it was very emotionally difficult to
leave that company and i was right look
at where it is today
um but i think the opportunity
came that the synergy was amazing these
are people that wanted to do amazing
things and yeah and i was privileged to
be uh
to be joining this founding team and
build this um
yeah i don't know it looks amazing okay
i have a few
interesting questions first one your
favorite subject in school
um that would be biology my
my mom was a biologist she was teaching
biology in high school um
and uh and and actually she has a
company
um doing alternative uh healthcare uh
products to medicine
uh that's her life mission and i really
always
liked following her so i learned five uh
if you thought
sorry in biology and i liked it very
much yeah amazing
okay and uh your role model one of your
role models
the cliche but you know you can't just
following every day at the new things
that this guy comes up elon musk i think
that's
i i know it's uh exactly why is it about
him is it his
entrepreneurial spirit he's breaking the
rules mentality
i think it's just dreaming big is one
thing after the other is just
inspiring to see how far away and how
big his
dreams and ambitions go uh which is
really really
uh uh inspiring to us you know we want
to solve big things and then
you know we look at what he's doing it's
like where where but you know
it's good to have such people to get
inspired from exactly okay and the most
important
and hardest question three words that
either you would choose to describe
yourself
or if i were to ask israel or nadav or
anybody else in the team who is lyran
grinberg
i think curious a team player and very
collaborative in nature
and pragmatic is a few words simple
words for a simple guy
that i would use to describe myself
this is amazing best of luck with this
one that i can't wait to to try and work
for you
thank you for the inspiration in the
meantime awesome
[Music]
you